Hello?
What's your favorite
scary movie?
Who is this?
[deep voice]
What's your favorite
scary movie?
Oh, Dr. Z,
is this you?
You really have to stop
with these prank calls.
But, serious, what's
your favorite scary movie?
Okay, we can talk
about that later,
but I'm filming
an episode right now.
Okay, sorry,
good luck.
Okay, bye!
Bye!
If you've attended
a sleepover party
anytime in the last
50 years,
chances are high
that you've encountered
a prank call like this.
Maybe you've even
made one yourself.
But for thousands of years
before the invention
of the telephone,
pranks fell under the purview
of a force
even more powerful
than rowdy teens.
It was left
to the Trickster Gods.
[intro music]
From Maui
in the Southern Hemisphere
to Amaguq in the North,
Trickster Gods and spirits
can be found in mythologies
across the globe,
and their stories are some
of the most fascinating ones,
like the Chinese tale
of Sun Wukong.
Also known as the Monkey King,
Sun Wukong used
his super-human strength
and impressive
shape-shifting abilities
to pester the other gods.
Once, he crashed
a heavenly banquet
that he was rudely
not invited to,
drank all the wine,
and then drunkenly stole
a bunch of immortality pills.
For his misbehavior,
the Monkey King was
imprisoned under a mountain
for 500 years,
and his escape provides fodder
for countless modern stories.
On the other side
of the world,
the Hopi people
of the American Southwest
told tales of Kokopelli.
According to one source,
Kokopelli is described
as a lascivious troublemaker
whose obscene behavior
provides an outlet
for people's less socially
acceptable desires
and reminds them
how they should behave.
This flute-playing
Trickster God
is also a fertility deity
who makes his own fun
as he travels the region
to spread corn seed
and encourage pregnancy,
sometimes through wild parties
and erotic dances.
This naughty figure
is so popular in the Southwest
that his image can be found
adorning countless
pieces of art and souvenirs.
And of course,
the Norse people gave us
what might be the most
widely known Trickster of all--
Loki, the god of mischief.
Much of what Marvel reveals
about Loki onscreen
is faithful to the old myths,
like his chaotic nature and
his long-held beef with Thor.
Even alligator Loki
has some foundation
in the old Eddas,
which mention Loki's
shape-shifting powers.
But the MCU's interpretation
of Loki is just that--
their interpretation.
In the original myths,
Thor and Loki
aren't even brothers,
so don't expect to be
an expert in Norse mythology
after watching Tom Hiddleston
charm his way
to the Avengers'
bad sides.
By the end of this video,
I'll tell you about
another Marvel superhero
inspired by a Trickster God,
but first, let's analyze
why the Trickster is
so common around the world.
It has to do with why myths
were told in the first place.
Before the Internet
and the scientific method
and even the concept
of writing things down,
humans told stories
for a few different purposes--
to explain the natural world,
to educate, and to entertain.
Myths, like monsters,
were created
to explain natural phenomena
and reflect human understanding
of the world around them,
and throughout time immemorial,
one thing that humans have
definitely known about nature
is that it's tricky.
Storms come
when you least expect them,
animals steal food
and other valuable resources,
and don't even get me started
on fire--
a bright light that provides
warmth and prepares your food
but can also burn you
and magically
turns wood into ash?
Sounds like
a very elaborate prank to me.
A Trickster Deity
is a convenient way
to explain these events.
Indeed, in many mythologies,
it's a Trickster who teaches
humanity how to harness fire.
Myths were also used
to codify social norms
for children and adults alike.
In mythology, the Trickster
often faces consequences
for their nefarious hijinks,
like when Sun Wukong
was imprisoned
for eating the very
peaches of immortality
that he was assigned
to protect.
These peaches, in addition
to the pills he stole before,
made Sun Wukong
extra invincible.
This lets everyone
who hears the story
know that an immortal god
could not run their punishment,
and neither can you.
And finally, Trickster stories
are fun and funny,
just like an entertaining myth
is supposed to be.
The chaos and randomness
inherent to a Trickster persona
often make us laugh.
Psychologists who study humor
have found a few theories
about what
makes something funny,
and incongruity
is one such theory.
We find something funny
when there's a mismatch
between our expectations
and reality,
and randomness creates
the opportunity
for that
hilarious juxtaposition.
In one Norse myth,
the giantess Skadi
demands to be compensated
for her father's murder
and insists
that one of the gods
needs to make her laugh.
Loki is apparently
the only Norse god
with a sense of humor,
so he tied one end
of a rope to a goat
and the other to a very...
sensitive part of his body
and then squealed with pain
as the goat ran away.
It must have been a
you-had-to-be-there kind of joke
because Skadi
was appropriately amused
and agreed
not to kill the gods.
So Tricksters can be found
in so many
different mythologies
because nature
is violent everywhere,
and the crafty qualities
of the Trickster
make this particular archetype
the perfect vehicle
for delivering moral
or practical lessons
in a fun, memorable package.
Across cultures, Tricksters
share many characteristics.
They're unpredictable,
are often able to shapeshift,
and they rely
on their quick wit
and penchant for mischief
to get them
out of hairy situations.
One Trickster that embodies
all of these qualities
is Anansi, the Trickster god
of knowledge and stories
who originated with
the Akan people
of Ghana in West Africa.
Christianity has been
the dominant religion in Ghana
for nearly a century,
but traditional Akan religion
is polytheistic.
Their pantheon is ruled
by a supreme Creator God
who goes by many names,
sometimes Nyame.
Second to Nyame
is Asase Yaa,
a goddess of the earth,
and together,
they have many children and
messengers of lesser power
known as Abosom.
Amongst some,
Anansi is the most important
of these children.
Often depicted as a spider
with a man's head,
or a man with eight legs,
Anansi plays a key role in
some fundamental Akan stories.
According to one,
the human world was
originally bereft of stories
until Anansi got bored one day
and decided to buy them
from his dad, Nyame.
The Sky God said that Anansi
could have his stories
for a steep price.
Anansi had to bring him four
of the hardest creatures
to catch--
Onini the python,
the hive of Mmoboro hornets,
Osebo the leopard,
and a fairy.
But Anansi uses his cunning
and his targets' weaknesses
to capture each one.
Impressed, Nyame granted Anansi
ownership of his stories,
and Anansi shared them
with humanity.
But lest you think
that makes him a good guy,
there's another story
where Anansi tries to horde
all the wisdom in the world
by trapping it in a pot
and sticking it
at the top of a tree.
Except the pot
was much bigger than Anansi,
and he had trouble
carrying it to the top
until his son, Ntikuma,
suggested he place it
on his back.
Anansi was so shocked
that he hadn't thought
of the answer himself
that the pot slipped
from his grip.
The pot shattered
on the ground,
and a storm carried away
the wisdom inside
to the rest of the world.
In yet another story,
Anansi brings disease
to the world
in an angry act of revenge
after his father took
all of his wives from him.
In Nyame's defense,
Anansi did promise to bring him
a beautiful wife
in exchange for one
of his delicious sheep,
and then used that sheep
to woo several new wives
who he kept for himself.
When the Atlantic slave trade
forced West Africans
from their home
and enslaved them
across an ocean,
they took stories of Anansi
with them.
They held onto him
as a symbol of resistance,
as a reminder that,
with a little bit
of cunning and resilience,
even something as small
as a spider
can escape
most tough situations.
Now stories of Anansi
have spread and morphed
across the Caribbean
and the Americas,
making their way into plenty
of popular media,
like Neil Gaiman's Mr. Nancy
from "American Gods,"
or Spider-Man.
That's right--it's Marvel canon
that in an alternate universe,
Earth 7082,
to be precise,
the very first Spider-Man
was Kwaku Anansi.
Whether it's displayed
on the silver screen,
told around a campfire,
or painted on the wall
of a cave,
Trickster stories remind us
to roll with the punches
that life throws at us
and to face obstacles
with cunning instead of force.
But Tricksters'
most important characteristic
is their unpredictability.
You never know if a Trickster
in a story will be the hero
or the villain
or merely the fool
providing comic relief.
Their flexibility is
what makes them so effective
and appealing.
And if you start
looking for them,
you'll see
Tricksters everywhere,
from Prometheus
tricking the gods
into giving us fire,
to the Roadrunner
"beep beeping" his way
through a world where the laws
of physics don't mean a thing.
Comment below with
your favorite Trickster figure,
and remember:
prank responsibly.
Accessibility provided by the
U.S. Department of Education.